when you write a novel you have to you
have to do engage in the process of
world-building right and you have all
these linked systems in reality just I
mean this is we have a reality of course
but in in you know the the New York City
reality of Kim Stanley Robinson's New
York 21:40 this is the cover art from
that from that book and sea levels have
risen by 50 years in a very short period
of time what does this mean for if
they've gone up by 50 feet for a city
that's on average 33 feet above sea
level what does this mean oh well you're
gonna have this super Venice that he
calls it right you've got you've got
flooding permanent flooding up to about
46th Street and what does that mean for
how people move about the city what does
that mean for in in a rapidly
decarbonizing economy where you don't
have long-distance transport that's as
easy what does that mean for food
production where do people get their
vegetables from where do people get
their produce from what does it mean for
the governance of small scale
organizations like an apartment co-op in
New York City right these are the types
of consequences you have a global change
you have the the the effects are felt
locally right and you have to play out
how all these things are going to work
right it's a model it's it's it's Kim
Stanley Robinson's opinion of what's
going to happen but I don't know I think
he's on to something in in most of these
things I know that Anna Lee Nuits spoke
recently about what was she talking
about science needs fiction and she had
such a fabulous example of how you have
to you have to come to grips with the
consequences of your narrative arc here
like okay so she's got this pirate in
the Arctic right who's on the internet a
lot on on shipboard and then she's like
oh god where does she get the internet
from right and so she had to invent
something to the technology that
provides Internet and the arc
and and you know this is this is the
notion you have to flesh out these
worlds you're playing with complex
systems it's actually not a huge point I
mean well it's it's an important point
but it's not it doesn't need to be
belabored I you know this is a fan art
for Paolo Bacigalupi 'he's the the
windup girl and you know in a
decarbonized world supply chains are
going to be highly altered right how do
you where do you get your food from
where's the energy to run manufacturing
where does that come from or if you have
if you have a an industrial plant that
produces whatever the machines that
you're trying to build where do you get
the power to run your machinery right
these are all things that come out in
the windup girl so that's point number
one point number two has to do with
imagining the future and imagining
better worlds and again there's this
terrific motion Hamid quote part of the
great political crisis we face in the
world today is a failure to imagine
plausible desirable futures or
surrounded by nostalgic visions
violently nostalgic visions fiction can
imagine differently I think this is an
enormous ly important idea and I feel
like it probably resonates with anyone
who is dissatisfied say with the current
administration and politics in America
we really are feeling this incredibly
violently in this nostalgic moment and
and typically these nostalgia z' are for
things that really didn't happen or they
certainly didn't happen the way we
remember them memory is it is an
imperfect process and so by writing
fiction we can imagine a better world
and I think this actually has really
important implications for the type of
fiction that we should write and and in
particular I I took all the slides out
of all the ridiculous movies that have
dealt with climate but there are lots of
them you don't have to like think very
hard about it and there what's the
commonality of them they're all
post-apocalyptic you know we
love and Max and Waterworld and you know
we didn't love Waterworld but we loved
the idea of it
these are these are post-apocalyptic
stories and they're not better futures
maybe there's some hair you know Katniss
Everdeen or whoever you know comes in
and and does the heroic thing and and
that's that's interesting but it's not
we're not imagining a better world I
think we need to do better in imagining
better worlds and the thing is there's
plenty of fiction that does exactly that
so that's the good news now we have to
convince Hollywood and whoever makes TV
shows
[Music]